お兄ちゃん肇社長はです皆さん精錬人にも now クローズでしょうか青年人は私も
よくわからないので今画面に出てると思いますこれがせいぜい機と呼ばれるものですね
仲良く我々の身の回り所青年期っていうのはさダイナモので
ぐらいなんですけども1的に静電気を作れる機械が存在しますそれがこちら
番ファーストいうものですでもば自分は便宜ばデータとツナ fp って言って
跳ね返てこの銀の玉のところで静電気を発生させる装置ですけどもう強いんですよ
そう遠いアウェイ静電気をですよねちょっといったい僕が身を持って食らってみようと
思いますで預けてみましょう
まあよくオレはー
大変な知能に眠い fudge するって大きな骨静電気が聞こえて溜まっていますで
もまあ考え関する本近くにならできます次ます
やばいやばい紙でちょっとした入っていうよりも目に見えてわかるレベルの静電気で
チェコの大便コップを使っているとロックに電気がたまるんですよ
tee
バッハ
ねえねえ難波の勝手に動いています
まってなんでてをいただければご存知て皆さんの司会で治るといけません
みんな食べてますポップな柄に行けるここに前期型持ってるんで触ってみます
wh
ああああああ
うよだて速い球がたなんかすごい
殴られた感じでした痛いとか何かあっとなりましたはずだ
終わってくらい強い静電気が作れるので今回弱に入ります挨拶だけしてみましょうか
持って
こんにちはー
入っていうことで100人人がいるので起こる静電気を発生させて宅に手を繋いで全員
関連すると思っあっあーっ
そして今日は100人全員で丸焦げにならば思いますとから実験でさんのせいでんき
みんなで歌まで見たいそれの100人まぞんやってみようと思います良いか
i take で100人でんきーがつながる準備ができました
みんな中
じゃあてきた目はいます
me
ああああああ
いや前変わっています
[音楽]
ああああああ
car
wh
he ある ai
ああああああ
me
detarame
ああああああ
yeah
a 2
[拍手]
goo
実験は1回だけうまくいっても成功とは言えません念のためもう1回やっておき
ましょう
皆さんもう1回いいですかぁ
そしてで着きます
car
deai しああああああああああああ
ran
ch
ああああああ
half a い
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
[音楽]
yeah
dea
me
ana あああっ